all right now I said I think that's a
more competent way of getting to this
result but the proof that you'd be
expected to produce is actually
backwards so let me give that to you
instead
so just to make sure we're all on the
same page
okay this this is up here okay that's
what in an exam they could totally say
to you this and then part two pets
bah-bah-bah
I've actually saw the question okay how
do you go about it because I'm going
back but it's okay you start yeah okay
now this is why I don't like this proof
even though it's sort of the one that
all the textbooks used and it'll be the
one that you actually probably will
memorize okay I don't like it cuz sort
of like why why this what does this have
to do with anything
okay where is this I at least get it
starts from something that I already
know
whereas this seems to come out of left
field okay as you can see all of my work
is actually be more or less identical
fighting in Reverse alright now if this
is what a different [ __ ] for some
unknown reason how do I differentiate
this yeah this is chain rule okay we
swallows sort of anticipated that
because all of this is changeable right
so therefore to make this work most of
you now let me write something in to
sort of clarify this right I'm
differentiating with respect to x1 of
differentiate it is a function of X okay
I'm trying to make the chain rule a bit
more obvious you so if you want
differentiating you go chain one here
right way used to clean that lucky U of
X your inside function okay but you guys
couldn't do you with different letters
right how does chamber web you
differentiate the inside and then you
differentiate the outside right so
differentiate the inside inside function
is B okay so I guess the derivative of B
would be when you can pull it be - if
you like or you can call it up to be on
yes that's your inside function or
rather the derivative
then what you want to do the rest of it
you have to do the outside function
which is half of something squared how
the top expense that's just a regular on
polynomial so you do when you do two all
polynomials you bring your power at the
front and then you reduce the power by
one right so that lands you back at V
that's the that's the outside so fast
we're good
all right now what am I going to do this
well I know what V is by definition they
is DX 1 DT okay and again you can see
this that's a chain know happening so
I'm gonna cancel my DX's which leaves me
with DV DT which again by definition is
X double ball for acceleration
okay so you can see I landed at the same
spot I think probably the reason why
textbooks like this is because there's
less of a arm let's put in T X's that's
what they think is harder I think this
conceptually makes more sense but this
is its equivalent all right I think this
is what that be would be for for you to
actually create so you need to remember
this happy square business and then from
there the rest of any questions